I'm sorry. I don't want to be an emperor.
I don't want to rule or conquer anyone.
I should like to help everyone if possible.
We all want to help one another; human beings are like that.
We want to live by each other's happiness, not by each other's misery.
We don't want to hate and despise one another.
Greed has poisoned men's souls,...
...has barricaded the world with hate,...
...has goose-stepped us into misery and bloodshed.
We have developed speed, but we have shut ourselves in.
Machinery that gives abundance has left us in want.
Our knowledge has made us cynical.
Our cleverness, hard and unkind.
We think too much and feel too little.
More than machinery, we need humanity.
More than cleverness, we need kindness and gentleness.
Without these qualities, life will be violent...
...and all will be lost.